ich denke die welt ist dafür gemacht das
mittelständige gibt dominik findest du
nicht dass es menschen gibt es dieses
system ausnutzen wenn ein mensch in not
gerät so dann wünsche ich mir dass wir
uns angucken und sagen ich sehe deine
noch
[Musik]
mal ganz im ernst kümmert ihr euch um
leute die weniger haben als ihr selbst
oder ist es gar nicht notwendig weil wir
so einen guten sozialstaat haben dass
hier keine existenzängste haben braucht
schafft es hier jeder unabhängig von
seiner sozialen herkunft nach oben ist
die meinungen dazu sind unterschiedlich
die meiner gäste auch mit 13 fragen
möchte ich sie heute bestenfalls zum
kompromiss führen und ihr könnt gerne
mitdiskutieren
deshalb geht die erste frage von 13
fragen an euch seid ihr der meinung dass
die soziale herkunft über die spätere
karriere entscheidet schreibt uns in die
kommentare
seid ihr bereit fühlt ihr euch gut jedes
pärchen nochmals an erinnern ist es ein
spiel also ich hoffe ihr habt spaß auch
wenn es ein sehr brisantes thema ist ich
weiß wir machen jetzt die erste runde
das bedeutet wir checken erstmal eure
position ab es ist eine erste schnelle
runde ohne worte wer meinen fragen
zustimmt der geht auf das gelbe fällt
wenn man fragen nicht zustimmt geht auf
das grüne feld
zweite frage wer als der meinung dass
wir in einem ungerechten land leben in
dem nicht jeder die chance hat karriere
zu machen und erfolgreich zu werden wenn
ihr zustimmt geht ihr auf gelb wenn ihr
nicht zustimmt geht er auf grün
[Musik]
mein name ist ja doch ich bin gründlich
renault tore
ich empfinde unser land als ungerecht
bei randgruppen wie menschen mit
migrationshintergrund menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen wirklich auf der
strecke bleiben und nicht genug
unterstützung bekommen ich denke mal
dieses meckern auf hohem level weil uns
geht es etwas viel besser als woanders
und ich kenne jetzt auch kein ort der
welt wo es besser strukturiert ist es in
deutschland dritte frage um armut zu
bekämpfen müssen menschen ohne
regelmäßigen erwerb ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen bekommen das bedeutet
jeder mensch der an familien mit wenig
geld auf wächst sollte monatlich so viel
geld bekommen dass er gut davon leben
kann wenn ihr zustimmt da lang wenn ihr
nicht zustimmt
[Musik]
ich bin im mietpool ich bin eine
deutsche mit migrationshintergrund weil
ich im iran geboren bin und in
deutschland als eine 13-jährige
unbegleitete flüchtlinge gekommen bin
ich finde bedingungslose grundeinkommen
sollte es nicht geben
es sollte härtere sanktionen geben weil
leider gottes menschen diese welt gibt
die uns ausnutzen
die sich darauf beruhen und natürlich
auch dem sprechen auch frau werten und
auch nicht einsehen sich umgehend weiter
zu entwickeln was mehr an unserem
sozialsystem fehlt ist die individuelle
hilfe ich glaube dass wir gut an einer
breiten masse aufgestellt sind aber das
ganz oft menschen durch das raster
fallen
nächste frage um finanzielle chancen für
alle zu erreichen sollten reiche
menschen noch mehr steuern zahlen und
besitz abgeben
[Musik]
ich finde nicht dass wir probleme
dadurch lösen dass reiche wer auch immer
das ist einfach mehr abgeben an ärmere
sondern ich glaube wir haben kein
problem in erster linie mit einer geld-
armut sondern mit nach chancen armut in
deutschland
ich finde das super reiche mehr steuern
zahlen können denn ihr reichtum basiert
immer auch darauf dass ganz viele andere
menschen daran beteiligt waren dass
dieser reichtum überhaupt existieren
konnte ok alles klar ist ich glaube die
positionen sind klar die fronten auch
wir machen jetzt weiter mit der zweiten
runde
ich habe jetzt eine fakten runde für
euch und es beginnt mit euch im
weltweiten vergleich liegt deutschland
was soziale gerechtigkeit angeht auf
platz 10 und steht damit vergleichsweise
ziemlich gut da sind wir mit unserem
sozialstaat besser dran als wir denken
okay überlegt euch gar nicht
ich finde die frage überhaupt schon in
anführungsstrichen irrelevant weil ich
beschäftige mich gerne mit einem problem
werden wenn es wirklich in meinem land
auftaucht egal ob jetzt andere länder
genauso viel damit zu kämpfen haben oder
weniger stark oder weniger schwach also
das ist mir ziemlich egal wie es anderen
ländern geht heute gießen in deutschland
ich würde da auch zustimmen also
natürlich ist eigentlich egal dass es
anderen auch schlechter geht und das
muss man ja auch anerkennen dass wir
bestimmte errungenschaften haben aber
man kann doch trotzdem noch dinge
verbessert und warum sollte man das
nicht machen also es sollte ja
eigentlich keinen stillstand geben
sondern darum gehen dass es uns möglich
besser geht und das hat für mich immer
so ein geschmack von dieser und in
afrika verhungern die kinder aussage wo
man dann damit irgendwie versucht zu
sagen ja beschwert euch mal nicht selbst
wenn es euch trotzdem auch schlecht geht
hier
ok ich kenne das noch aus meiner
schulzeit da bin ich zum beispiel mit
einer 4 nach hause gekommen und dann
habe ich gesagt hätte ich war gar nicht
so schlecht weil es gab noch ganz viele
die hat oder 6 da sind ein paar besser
gewesen und deswegen ich schließe mich
da auch von meinen vorrednern an das
geht nicht darum wo wir stehen sondern
was wir verbessern können und die
probleme die wir hier haben anzugehen
die nächste frage geht an euch
deutschland es reich und trotzdem ist
jedes fünfte kind von armut bedroht
spricht das nicht gegen ein
funktionierenden sozialstaat eigentlich
ja aber das liegt daran weil wir diese
chancengleichheit die in deutschland
nicht habe das heißt es gibt oft auch
arme kinder die nicht studieren können
und akademiker kinder studieren warum
warum muss das denn so einen sozialstaat
zuwachs gebe es gab eigentlich und ist
daher ein schritt auf mich zukommen weil
du der these zustimmen
ich stimme des caesar auf jeden fall zu
und aber es ist dann auch so
widersprüchlich ja es gibt da natürlich
auch gerechte system um an der seite
muss ich musste eigentlich so hier
massiv dass sich gar nicht bewegt ja
also ich denke die welt ist dafür
gemacht dass es arme und reiche und
mittelständige gibt und es wird immer
menschen geben die mehr haben als andere
aber ich bin natürlich dafür dass man
die ganz armen dann ein wenig reicher
macht aber die natur gibt es manchmal
nicht so wieder weil man verlangt ja
dann aber manchmal auch von den menschen
dass sie sich mehr bewegen mehr machen
mehr tun was aber nicht immer in ihrer
macht steht und dann bist du automatisch
in einem karussell drin
ich finde nicht dass es normal ist dass
es armut und reichtum gibt im sinne
fordern dass es im naturzustand ist also
als wäre die welt so geschaffen worden
ich glaube schon dass wir in einer welt
leben können der niemand in armut leben
muss und ich glaube auch dass es zum
beispiel da keine kinderarmut in
deutschland brauchte das ist nicht
einfach so etwas also ganz oft sagt man
ja wer arm ist es selber schuld so und
ich würde dem nicht zustimmen aber dass
es etwas was debattiert wird die
argumentation wird ja spätestens bei
kindern irgendwie schwierig wie man
begründen soll wie sie es verdient haben
in armut zu leben was die gemacht oder
nicht gemacht haben und ich würde schon
immer den anspruch hoch halten dass es
möglich ist das ist eigentlich für uns
alle reicht und dass wir dafür sorgen
können dass jeder nicht in armut und
jeder auch ein würdevolles leben haben
kann
in deutschland ist ein reiches land es
kann nicht sein dass es familien gibt
die zum beispiel keine bücher
schulbücher für kinder kaufen können
oder nicht auf die klassenfahrt ihre
kinder schicken können
und das ist sehr bedauerlich natürlich
ist eingelassen normal weil ich es nicht
anders kenne ich rede von mir selbst
also wenn ich heute was anderes lernen
kann dann nehme ich das natürlich mit
ich glaube man muss immer sehen was ist
der ansatzpunkt um dinge besser zu
machen und da würde ich mal sagen gerade
bei kindern die er nun wirklich
überhaupt nichts dafür kennen
können wir ihre eltern sind muss man
eben zum beispiel über bildung würde ich
sagen ist die wichtigste
sozialpolitische aufgabe die wir haben
dass jeder eine gute bildung bekommt
jeder datei haben kann nämlich genau das
was du sagst eigentlich schaffen kann es
mal besser zu haben sich da in pier
auszuarbeiten und zu sagen ich will
irgendwie mehr erreichen im leben ok
meine frage bezog sich ja darauf ob das
quasi nicht gegen einen sozial
ungerechten sozialstaat spricht du bist
trotzdem nur ein paar zentimeter nach
vorne gegangen
dann hast du gerade gesagt hat spricht
eher für das nächste feld ja hatte ich
sagte okay dann würde ich zur nächsten
runde bekommen wir haben jetzt eine
persönliche runde da hat jeder von euch
die möglichkeit seine persönliche
geschichte zu diesem thema mit uns zu
teilen seine persönlichen erfahrungen zu
teilen meine siebte frage geht an dich
sarah was macht dich wütend wenn du an
unser sozialsystem denkst ich bin selber
indem hartz4 haushalt aufgewachsen ich
weiß dass kinderarmut ist weil ich es
erlebt habe ich weiß wie schwierig das
ist da raus zu kommen und es wird nicht
einfacher dadurch dass wir nicht nur
also dadurch dass wir hartz4 haben und
dadurch dass diese sanktionen gibt in
unserem sozialstaat dass davon geredet
wird als wären das sozialschmarotzer als
werden dass menschen als werden als
wären die eine last für die gesellschaft
und irgendwann redet man sich das dann
auch selber ein und ich glaube das macht
krank das macht viele menschen krank und
ich glaube dass es nicht nur schlimm für
die leute die hartz 4 beziehen oder für
die leute die arbeitslos sind sondern
auch für die leute die ganz knapp drüber
sind und sich denken da darf ich nicht
rein rutschen weil das wird schlimm und
dann bin ich außerhalb der gesellschaft
dann werden menschen mich nicht mögen
dann werden menschen denken ich bin
schuld an ihren problemen und ich finde
das stimmt nicht
und gerade mit diesen reformen die es
gab wurden meiner meinung nach
unglaublich viele menschen an den rand
der gesellschaft gedrängt und wenn wir
jetzt immer von so gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt reden dann müssen wir uns
doch fragen auf was es mit diesen
menschen die gar keinen also die das
gefühl haben von der politik sitzen
gelassen worden zu sein
das war sarahs persönliche erfahrungen
wenn ihr zustimmt könnt ihr gerne einen
schritt auf sie zugehen wenn nicht könnt
ihr auch einen schritt nach hinten
laufen
könnt auch ins nächste feld ok dafür hat
nicht gereicht
du lachst was denkst du dazu ich finde
das ist eine total richtige beobachtung
also wenn ich mir anschaue dass menschen
eben ja häufig dann auch in hartz4
bleiben das macht mich richtig wütend
weil ich finde das ist eigentlich ja
gedacht gewesen
damit jemand der eben auf den ersten
anlauf ist nicht scharf direkt wieder
einen job zu finden dass der weiter
qualifiziert wird dass er irgendwie neue
fähigkeiten lernt vielleicht irgendwie
wenn eine krankheit dazu gekommen ist
die möglichkeit bekommt sich zu kurieren
und dann wieder aufzustehen und ich
finde es so schlimm dass das irgendwie
so ein dauerzustand häufig ist das man
halt einmal hat vier immer hartz iv und
das kann nicht sein dass sie was denkst
du gerade noch gesagt dass das nicht
anders kennt und man diese und dann ich
bin auch unter sehr armen verhältnissen
aufgewachsen aber in einer
arbeiterfamilie und da gibt es auch
probleme also da sind wir auch gerade
mal so über die runden gekommen
wenn du da warst abzahlen muss der miete
zahlen muss und und und und darfst du
auch deine kopfschmerzen also ich sehe
bei diesem modell hartz4 ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob sie unbedingt erneuert werden
muss 3.0 oder was weiß ich so da bin ich
nicht so auf dem laufenden wie die
profis aber ich sehe viel mehr positives
als negatives
was sagst du dazu sarah ich glaube das
was wir halt bei hartz4 gemerkt haben
wir müssen wir uns die reha das ja
gerade angesprochen hat irgendwie mal
fragen warum bleiben diese menschen in
arbeitslosigkeit und ganz oft ist diese
erzählung drum herum
ja weil die sich bequem eingerichtet
haben die holen sich jetzt ihren
alkohol- und ihre zigaretten und setzten
sich auf die couch
aber eigentlich würde ich sagen das hat
vier in sich einfach arbeits fehler hat
also dass das system an sich
funktioniert so nicht weil leute so
abgeschreckt werden schon heute nicht
raus fehler auf alkoholiker oder nein
ich nehme mal nicht arbeiten wollen er
wollte ich das gar nicht unterstellen
aber das ist etwas womit man oft seien
so begegnet wird wenn man über die
menschen redeten hartz 4 leben und ich
glaube es braucht eine grundsicherung
die die menschen absichert und die ein
positives menschenbild hat und nicht
einfach davon ausgeht die wollen eh
nichts machen deswegen würde ich sagen
hat vier macht gerade sehr viel schlecht
und deswegen muss es reformiert werden
und zwar sehr bald
also ich habe jetzt sehr intensiv nicht
hat mich mit hartz iv empfängern befasst
weil ich jetzt eine tv sendung mache und
ich bin experte für hartz iv empfänger
und ich habe die erfahrung gemacht dass
wir auch für sie job besucht haben sie
auch natürlich in das normale leben
besucht haben zu integrieren und die
gucken die ich anderen sagen warum soll
ich arbeiten gehen die kriegt vom
jobcenter geld und da kommen wir wieder
zu unseren sozialstaat zurück und da hat
mich als coach keine antwort gehabt zu
sagen ja stimmt du hast recht aber es
geht um deine würde dass du in deinem
spiegeln sich anschaut und wirklich ein
vorbild für dein kind bis und diese
menschen haben keine vorbilder diese
menschen haben niemanden der sie an die
hand nimmt und in den weg weist
und das ist genau unser grundsätzliches
problem hier in deutschland sie kriegen
einfach geld und sie sind auch nicht
motiviert und sich zu bewerben aber sie
ist gar nicht können weil sie es noch
nie gemacht haben woher auch und dieser
mut zu besitzt auch mal auch ein neues
leben anzufangen denn es ist wahnsinnig
schwer und deshalb finde ich dass man
nicht einfach nur mit geld diese
menschen unterstützen kann sondern auch
bildung momentan coachen als mentor an
deren seite stehen ich habe viele
waisenkinder und flüchtlingskinder ich
sage okay wenn ich nicht mental für sie
da bin ich nur ihnen geld gebe bringt
das doch nicht weiter dann geben sie das
kind aus und das war auch bei hartz iv
empfänger genau so sie haben geld von
uns bekommen was haben sie gemacht haben
innerhalb von zwei wochen das gesamte
geld ausgegeben und das ist auch nicht
sieht und weckte sein das heißt man muss
ihnen beibringen wie sie auch haushalten
können das haben sie ja nie gelernt und
uns jetzt hier muss man dass deren
kinder das anders lernen und da haben
wir große lücke hier in deutschland da
müssen unbedingt ansätzen finde ich also
ich war an diesem punkt von so an die
hand nehmen und ich glaube da würde ich
dir voll zustimmen
das ist so voll das problem dass die
leute die einen eigentlich an die hand
nehmen sollen also wir haben jetzt die
jobcenter gleichzeitig die leute sind
die einen sanktionieren das heißt man
geht da hin und weiß das ist eigentlich
der ab die personen die zu dessen
vertrauensverhältnis haben soll das ist
die person mit der ich über meine
weiterbildung rede die mit mir darüber
geredet wie es weitergeht aber wenn ich
zu einem termin nicht komme wenn ich das
nicht mache was die person möchte und
mich zum beispiel nicht für den job
bewerben der befristet ist schlecht
bezahlt und mit er gar nichts mehr am
hut hat dann wird sie mich sanktionieren
und zu sanktionen kriegen auch schon
minderjährige kinder angedroht wenn sie
zu termin beim jobcenter
nicht erscheinen und ich denke da muss
man sich fragen was macht das denn mit
menschen die versuchen
vertrauensverhältnis zu jemandem
aufzubauen wenn sie gleichzeitig immer
angst haben vor den menschen und das
meine ich mit diesen muss das umdrehen
und sich überlegen wie man auf die
menschen zugeht will dich kurz darauf
aufmerksam machen dass ihr euch beide
gerade in einem punkt einig seid also
ich kann euch gerne aufeinander zugehen
ich würde vielleicht in einem punkt
widersprechen weil also ich finde zum
einen also ich glaube die leute in den
jobcentern das sind keine bösen leute in
der regel sondern die machen ja diesen
job weil sie wirklich helfen wollen und
keiner sucht irgendwie nach
möglichkeiten jemand zu sanktionieren
über 90 prozent von hartz iv empfängern
kommen überhaupt nie in kontakt mit
sanktions und deswegen wollte ich noch
mal so eine lanze brechen auch für die
leute die ja mit den leuten auch
zusammenarbeiten aus den jobcentern
herauskommt also ich möchte da noch
einmal ganz klar sagen dass er so ich
kritisiere dass das mit den sanktionen
passiert ich habe ja selber kontakt zu
menschen in den jobcentern gehabt da
durch das ist ja nicht also das problem
sind ja nicht die menschen die in den
jobcentern sitzen
wir haben gesagt wir machen das mit den
sanktionen und es hat also ist
funktioniert nicht um die menschen aus
der langzeitarbeitslosigkeit zu holen
und dann würde ich eher dafür plädiert
dass wenn die würde des menschen
unantastbar ist dann ist auch das
existenzminimum unantastbar achte frage
an dich massiv du bist auch in einem
nicht reichen elternhaus aufgewachsen
und trotzdem sagst du in deutschland
kann es jeder schaffen
jaja schaffen jeder in seiner eigenen
welt jeder auf seinem eigenen weg jeder
durch seine eigene tür
das ist absolut möglich in deutschland
weit ich mich auch damit befassen was
woanders auf der welt so abgeht so und
also mit so einer großen
bevölkerungsdichte auf so engem raum
trotzdem deine träume verwirklichen zu
können ist am deutsch in deutschland am
besten also das ist in amerika viel
weiter weg davon
obwohl die filme besser sind dort und es
einfach so dass der fakt natürlich ist
in schweden viel krasser als hier aber
da gibt es halt nur fünf menschen auf 20
und da ist ja so und ich habe fünf
ausbildungen angefangen und mich dafür
dann entschieden die ausfallen zu lassen
weil ich gemerkt habe das ist nichts für
mich aber ich habe mir halt so den luxus
genommen immer wieder was neues zu
finden so und habe mich da immer
durchgesetzt aber immer wenn ich gemerkt
habe ist passt nicht zu mir habe ich weg
weggeschmissen und überlegt was mache
ich es als nächstes und ja da habe ich
natürlich auch viele kriminelle sachen
gemacht dass man einfach so über die
runden kommt was natürlich nicht
gutzuheißen ist aber letztendlich habe
ich meinen weg gefunden und als ich
meinen weg gefunden habe habe ich
nochmal 100 ab und da uns gehabt weil
die wird nichts geschenkt und das leben
ist kein wunschkonzert
und ich rate nur jeden so 100 prozent zu
geben zu dass was er liebt und alles
andere links und rechts liegen zu lassen
also hast du auch die kriminellen
machenschaften überhaupt gebraucht um
über die runden zu kommen
ich bin ohne goldenen löffel
aufgewachsen ohne monatlichen beitrag
von den eltern sondern war immer sehr
ausgegrenzte einzige braune in der
ganzen schule und da hast du schon früh
gemerkt so du bist anders als die
anderen und ich war absolut ausgegrenzt
und das hat mich aber auch dann
motiviert in meiner pubertät und
trotzdem sagst du es kann jeder
zumindest auf seiner art in deutschland
schaffen wie was genau führt zu diesem
gedanken bei die natürlichen lockerer
spruch vor mir aber auf deutschem boden
besser als in der rest der welt ihr
könnt gerne einen schritt auf ihn
zugehen weil ich weil ich seine
definition von erfolg so ein bisschen
geteilt habe das erfolgs muss nicht
heißen man ist es super reich oder so
sein meinte jeder in seinem eigenen
leben kann auf jeden fall vorankommen
und das teile ich auf jeden fall also
jeder kann sich weiterentwickeln
davon bin ich überzeugt und natürlich
seine gesinnung
du wirst auch einen halben schritt
ich möchte einmal erzählen wie das ist
sanktioniert zu werden ich wurde drei
mal in meinem leben zu 100 prozent das
gab es damals noch 100 prozent
sanktioniert
das bedeutet keine grundsicherung und
keine kosten der unterkunft man hat kein
geld
zweimal davon musste ich auf die straße
drei monate das macht kein mieter mit
und wir haben hierbei verschiedene
sachen gesprochen und zum einen es muss
eine grundsicherung deswegen heißt sie
grund
sich herum geben das ist existenziell
seien grundbedürfnisse sind
menschenrechte meiner meinung nach und
das zweite wichtige und das wurde ja
auch schon öfter gesagt teilhabe das es
so wichtig man kann sich das vorstellen
ich habe so ein din a 4 zettel bekommt
das heißt lebensmittelgutscheine und mit
so einem zettel geht man dann ein
supermarkt da ist eine mega lange
schlange hinter ein mann hat 40 euro das
ist das was man kriegt dafür dass man
eine woche einkaufen zigaretten und
alkohol sind dabei übrigens
ausgeschlossen weil das sind ja alles
nur trinke und rauche und damit steht
man an dieser kasse und glaubt mir man
schämt sich einfach nur und scham führt
immer dazu dass man sich isoliert und
deswegen darwin chancengleichheit für
mich dass man menschen auch wenn sie
wenig haben das gleiche zugesteht und in
dem falls das geld ganz alleine wenn du
in der lage bist wo man quasi ums
überleben kämpft kannst du es kaum zu
schaffen
ja du hast ich bin für sanktionen
ausgesprochen was sagst du denn jetzt zu
dominiks geschichte also ich finde
irgendwo muss es in die möglichkeit
geben dass man auch tatsächlich
irgendwie ein effekt spürt man wenn man
sagt okay hier so pflichttermin oder
irgendwas wenn ich das irgendwie dreimal
nicht mache das dann irgendeine
konsequenz folgt aber so dass ergreift
mich total wenn du das so erzählt und
ich finde es kann nicht sein dass
menschen auf der straße landen weil sie
vom jobcenter kein geld mehr für ihre
wohnung bekommen also ich würde auch
sagen so was die wohnungen und irgendwie
heizkosten oder so energie das muster
auf jeden fall raus aus den sanktionen
das muss irgendwie gewährleistet sein
weil ich meine bibel zu den sonst
überhaupt anfangen damit einen schritt
nach vorne zu gehen wenn dir so die
quasi die grundlage unterm hintern
weggezogen wird dominik findest du nicht
dass es menschen gibt dass dieses system
ausnutzen
also dann die geschichte für mich sehr
emotional und die mich auch zuschauer
mit aber findest du nicht dass es
menschen wie nie wirklich das geld
nehmen nur für andere dinge ausgeben
wenn jemand in deutschland mit 800 euro
im monat lebt und sagt das ist das was
was mir reicht und also ich bin für
selbstbestimmte lebenskonzepte und wenn
das jemand als sein lebenskonzept sieht
dann akzeptiere ich das weil darin sind
auch immer gründe verankert so sehe ich
das und am ende ergibt sich ein
miteinander und diese miteinander sollte
aber jeder entscheiden dürfen wie ihr
leben marc dominik du warst einige jahre
obdachlos was ist denn deine persönliche
haltung zum thema chancengleichheit
das ist bei mir ist das eine
familiengeschichte so meine großeltern
sind die menschen zu denen ich irgendwie
den meisten bezug habe und die ich sehr
geliebt habe und die aber verstorben
sind und meine mama war einfach krank
und deshalb sie hatte ganz viele
verschiedene diagnosen deswegen an mit
depressionen das mit schizophrenie
geendet und sie ist in der geschlossenen
anstalt rein und raus gegangen und sie
war so überfordert von ihrer krankheit
und dieser situation dass sie ihre
vormundschaft abgelegt hat das bedeutet
sie wollte und konnte nicht länger meine
mutter sein und hat mich dann mit 16
jahren quasi in die welt entlassen hat
gesagt ich kann nicht mehr für dich da
sein und packte seine koffer und geht
raus und so bin ich dann quasi als
jugendlicher schon zum ersten mal auf
der straße gelandet und das ist eben so
ganz viele geschichten passieren jeder
hat ein schicksal und oft ist das
unverschuldet und ab dem moment bin ich
aber ein straßenjunge und in meinem fall
war es so ich bin noch weiter zur schule
gegangen zwei jahre und ich habe mein
abitur noch auf der straße gemacht aber
nicht weil ich irgendwie so gerne da war
sondern weil die schule mir der letzte
halt war wo ich das gefühl hatte ich
wäre normal wenn mich jemand gefragt hat
was bist du konnte ich immer noch sagen
ich bin ein schüler und nicht ich bin
ein straßenjunge und deswegen ganz viele
sachen passieren einfach und ab dem
moment bist du nicht mehr der selbe
obwohl derselbe mensch bist was hättest
du vom staat erwartet dass dass das
nicht passiert wäre mit 16
also für mich ist das phänomen
verantwortung weiter schieben
der lehrer sagt ich habe eine ganze
klasse zu unterrichten geht zum
vertrauenslehrer der vertrauenslehrer
sagt ja da gibt es das kinder- und
jugendnotdienst das kinder- und
jugendnotdienst sagt du bist vielleicht
minderjährig aber auch jugendliche dann
geht es zum jugendamt und das jugendamt
sagt du wirst vielleicht bei der
familien behörde zuständig also keiner
waffe grund niemand nimmt sich jemanden
an und genau das ist wenn ein mensch in
not gerät so dann wünsche ich mir dass
wir uns angucken und sagen ich sehe
deine not ich stelle mich an deine seite
und ich begleite dich so lange bist du
da wieder rausgekommen ist und dann
würden wir auch nicht so viele menschen
verlieren so machst du da zu 100 prozent
seine meinung also sehr rührende
geschichte und ja wir brauchen menschen
die uns unterstützen
es gibt nämlich menschen die einen
unterstützungen helfen sie es nicht der
deutsche staat gewesen der zum beispiel
mich integriert hat ich bin mit 13 als
flüchtlingskind unbegleitete
flüchtlingskinder damals in den 80er
jahren nach deutschland gekommen
aus dem iran und wie gesagt aber und
lehrer mentoren mein vater der im iran
war dem ich dann halt praktisch
gezwungen hat und mich hier zu
integrieren um anzukommen und auch die
werte die ich mitgebracht habe aus
meiner heimat und ich glaube das ist
auch eine sehr wichtige punkt wo kommt
man hier welche werte bringen man denn
mit und diese selbstbewusstsein und das
ist spielt auch eine große rolle
es ist einfach schwer als migrant sich
hier in deutschland immer zu beweisen zu
müssen wer bin ich woher komme ich was
habe ich erreicht das heißt wenn ich
eine putzfrau wäre hätte ich vielleicht
nicht so mit standing wie wenn ich jetzt
eine unternehmerin bin und dass wir
nicht schade und traurig und deshalb
gibt es auch frauen besonders frauen die
sich natürlich auch nicht trauen und
deshalb brauchen diese menschen die zu
uns kommen auch diese motivation dass du
es auch schaffen
bereitet dir denn die vorstellung sorge
dass reiche in diesem land mehr geld
abgeben müssen
also ehrlich gesagt es ist jetzt nicht
meine größte sorge
so aber ich finde und da sind wir wieder
so ein bisschen bei der frage wären
jetzt viel darüber gesprochen was muss
der der staat irgendwie an geld geben
und das ziel ist aber ja nicht dass man
irgendwie die ganze zeit in seinem leben
wir an seinem tropf irgendwie am start
hinten man bekommt von dem irgendwie
mehr oder weniger geld sondern das ziel
ist ja man verdient wieder selber
irgendwann so viel geld man hat auch so
viele anreize dass man immer mehr
arbeitet immer mehr lernt dabei sich
weiterqualifiziert und immer näher da
hin kommt was man sich eigentlich selber
wünscht zu machen
das ist halt leider nicht der regelfall
aber wenn jemand aus 14 familie kommt
zur schule geht lernt sein abi macht
dann irgendwie studieren geht oder eine
ausbildung macht und irgendwie sein
traum lebt dann muss es doch möglich
sein dass man dann irgendwann auch reich
ist so und wenn dann aber jemand kommen
sagt entschuldigung so jetzt musst du
aber mehr als 50 prozent von dem was du
da verdienst wieder abgeben wer will
denn da noch reich werden
also ich glaub nur weil jetzt jemand aus
mittelstand gesagt bekommt du musst 50
prozent des geldes abgeben wenn ein paar
millionen also wenn er dann quasi reich
ist später und dann von seinen millionen
da 50 abgeben muss ich glaube ich das
eher demotiviert ist ich glaubte er
würde dann sagen ich bin millionär kann
mich doch jucken ich hab dann eben
richtig viel geld
wir haben die leute sich das erarbeiten
vielleicht haben sie vielleicht haben
sie bis sie 32 wurden irgendwie studiert
und ihren arsch aufgerissen für eine
stelle die sie dann zu einer nächsten
stelle gebracht hat wovon sie heute
profitieren und diesen weg kennen wir
alle nicht und wenn das dazu führt dass
diese personen dann mehr arbeitsplätze
gibt und mehr wohlstand verteilt dann
ist es ja sinnvoll wenn viele menschen
reich sind aber auch gleichzeitig
verstehen dem system was zurückzugeben
so also
ich finde das krass aber dass du sagst
also ja sie geben dann zurück aber du
hast gesagt eine macht das nichts aus
ich glaube schon in einer erfolg hat
wenn ein erfolg hat tut es schon so zehn
meter sagt warum muss ich so viel geben
ich mache doch da so viel da so viel da
so viel ich bin der überzeugung
überproportional krass von
bildungssystem von unserem rechtssystem
von überhaupt ein ganzes dem dass wir
hier in frieden leben in deutschland
profitiert und dadurch in ruhe sein
business aus bearbeiten konnte in ruhe
hart arbeiten konnte mit verschiedensten
leuten zusammen da war der hat auch
überprüfen
aber ich sag mal so man muss auch
erfolgreichen leute schätzen
ich finde dass das gerade ganz
interessant es gibt so zwei sachen und
unternehmer zu sein finde ich super und
geld zu verdienen um das dann vielleicht
auch wieder richtig einzusetzen es gibt
aber super reiche menschen
ich habe jemanden kennen gelernt dass
ein name steht als drogeriekette
obendrauf immer dessen mit multi
milliardär und das muss es hier nicht
geben
und kein mensch braucht eine milliarden
euro aber der kann ja nichts dafür und
wir sind jetzt die wochen gehen dann
wisst ihr aber in der diktatur du gehst
mir im kopf und sagt das geld brauchst
ja gar nicht gibt und im bezahl genug
steuern glaube ich würde dir voll
zustimmen sind eben also ich finde die
debatte um so reiche besteuern und es
wird auch deswegen so komisch gefühlt
weil es jetzt ja auch ganz oft so ist
dass leute die eigentlich so voll
mittelständisch sind wirklich viel zu
viele steuern bezahlen für das was sie
machen so ist und ich glaube es braucht
halt diesen schiff zu den menschen die
ganz ganz krass mit dem reichtum
woanders stehen und da braucht es andere
debatten darüber und mir kann keiner
erzählen dass sohn jeff bezos nur durch
seine eigene arbeitskraft und sein
ideenreichtum reich ist sondern da hängt
ja auch das daran dass er diese ganzen
mitarbeiter hatte hängt übrigens auch
mit daran dass er sie nicht unbedingt
gut behandelt und dass sie nicht
unbedingt gut bezahlt sind
ja ich wollte noch hinzufügen dass es
auch reiche menschen gibt ja natürlich
auch einfach geerbt haben also wirklich
reichtum vererbt bekommen
haben und ich glaube gelesen zu haben
dass 50 prozent des reichtums der
konzentration wirklich einfach vererbt
wird ist darauf nicht viele steuern
glaube ich abzugeben und daran sollten
wir auch eben werken das also ich bin
jetzt nicht daran interessiert den
milliardär zu gehen und zu sagen das
haus das gibst du mir jetzt mal sondern
schon wenn jetzt die bases seine nächste
generation keine ahnung ob kinder hat
ehrlich gesagt aber wenn er seinen
kindern vererben würde dann wäre ich
aber daran interessiert dass die kinder
dann nicht so viel in dem maße karl
vererbt bekommen können ohne auch
bisschen was an die gesellschaft
abzugeben
also das mit dem englischen königreich
also es wird immer erbe wird es immer
geben und jeder streitet sich um erbe
ist eigentlich ein gutes menschen so was
mein vater geschafft hat begibt dann
nehme ich ihm an und für ist weiter also
ob es betriebe sind ob es geld ist
manchmal erdmann schulden
man muss dafür geradestehen das ist das
ist ja das ist ja das was der mitgegeben
wird also nicht an dann geht nicht nur
darum dass das dass die ungerechte
situation ist in der wir leben dass es
sein kann dass a ja voll viel erbt und
reich auf die welt kommt quasi und du
zum beispiel in schulden auf die welt
kommst das ist ja quasi die
ungerechtigkeit über die wir heute
sprechen wollen genau aber ich genau ich
glaube es ganz gut wenn man es noch mal
angucken was ist eigentlich die
ungerechtigkeit ich glaube nicht dass es
ungerecht ist wenn manche menschen
millionen verdienen so sondern ich finde
das ungerecht wenn manche menschen gar
nichts verdienen und das ist doch das
worüber wir reden müssen wie können wir
dafür sorgen dass im prinzip wirklich
jeder dahin kommen kann
und da würde ich auch sagen da sind wir
noch nicht in der gesellschaft und das
ist auch das wirklich so was mich so
sauer macht dass wir also ich finde
dieser neid der bringt uns überhaupt
nicht weiter weil das hier muss ja sein
dass da alle hinkommen können und dass
es eben nicht so sehr daran hängt wo
komme ich her wie sehe ich aus was habe
ich für nachnamen bin ich eine frau oder
ein mann sondern dass es eben auch nicht
davon abhängt irgendwie in welchem
stadtviertel berdych groß sondern dass
wir und da würde ich sagen da müssen wir
ganz viel auch rein investieren so aber
wir müssen erstmal gucken was brauchen
mehr und das ist das
exzellente bildung für alle ihr könnt
auch gerne nach
also ich finde das wichtig dass du über
diese voraussetzung redet sie nicht da
sind wie geschaffen werden müssen ich
finde es gibt aber noch eine zweite
seite von voraussetzungen nämlich dass
wir dann sicherstellen müssen dass wenn
alle millionäre werden dass der reichtum
der dabei entsteht nicht dadurch
entsteht dass wir zum beispiel
produktion so auslagern das woanders
also dass eine produktion darauf
angewiesen ist dass woanders leute zu
krass niedrigen löhne im kreis
schlechten arbeitsbedingungen arbeiten
weil ganz oft wird reichtum auch dadurch
möglich dass leute in schlechten
bedingungen arbeiten
und wenn wir sagen alle werden reicht
dann müssten wir auch dafür sorgen dass
der reichtum niemals darauf beruht dass
irgendwo anders leute ausgebeutet werden
genau dass es staatliche aufgabe
rahmenbedingungen zu stecken
arbeitsbedingungen so meine das ist
total wichtig dass es eben nicht nur
durch ausbeutung möglich ist irgendwie
sich daran zu bereichern
voll bei dir auf der anderen seite ist
natürlich und das finde ich muss man im
hinterkopf behalten jemand der
arbeitsplätze schafft als unternehmer
und da will ich jetzt gar nicht über die
presse sprechen sondern vielleicht eher
über denjenigen der irgendwie die
bäckerei aufmacht oder vielleicht auch
irgendwie ein start-up gegründet oder
irgendwas und damit die arbeitsplätze
schafft ein risiko eingeht und dass der
davon auch ein bisschen mehr profitiert
weil er auch genauso viel mehr verlieren
kann
das finde ich schon fair na also der
muss auch wenn man irgendwie was
probiert und man scheitert dann muss man
irgendwie auch so ein netz auch wieder
fallen können wäre mir jetzt sehr lange
sehr viel sehr intensiv diskutiert jetzt
möchte ich aber dass wir von der
diskussion alleine weg kommen und sagen
was sind eigentlich die lösungsansätze
was wären mögliche lösungen
deswegen habe ich jetzt die konsensrunde
für euch und ihr seid ja schon fast alle
im konsens im mittelfeld vielleicht
treffen uns gleich alle hier die erste
frage an euch kinder sind nicht schuld
daran wenn sie in armut aufwachsen wir
sind uns eigentlich dass wir allen
jungen menschen unabhängig ihrer
herkunft eine chance geben müssen
konkreter vorschlag sollten wir
bundesweit mehr initiativen gründen die
jungen menschen perspektiven aufzeigen
ihnen werte vermitteln und damit ihr
selbstvertrauen stärken wunderbar zeiten
ja
ihr seid alle sind zwölfter frage wollen
wir uns auf ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen für die einigen die in
familien mit sehr wenig geld aufwachsen
es ist ja immer ein bisschen schwieriger
und einkommen ist begriff eigentlich ist
das was du beschreibst kein
grundeinkommen sondern die
grundsicherung im rahmen ja ja dann will
ich dabei ihr müsst auch nicht noch
näher kommen gegen mona aber ihr könnt
entweder stehen bleiben oder wieder nach
hinten gehen sozusagen dreizehnte frage
letzte frage wie wäre es wenn kinder mit
sehr wenig geld ein konto bekommen
würden
dieses geld auf dem konto das wären
steuergelder aus erbschaften
der staat würde monatlich darauf
einzahlen und das konto wer ab einem
bestimmten alter verfügbar
das wäre dann zum beispiel nutzbar für
den ersten umzug oder fürs studium und
vorher dürften die gar nicht an dieses
konto 3d ab einem bestimmten alter songs
ist wahrscheinlich oder so zum beispiel
und da sage ich schon das geld wird in
ein geiles auto landen
von meiner patentante für meinen
führerschein bekommen weil meine mutter
mir das nicht finanzieren konnte und
davon habe ich mein umzug finanziert
also hier betreffen ja wirklich um die
kinder die mit sehr wenig geld
aufwachsen ja dass sie überhaupt die
möglichkeit haben zum beispiel ihre
nervöse finanzieren oder studium für
mich so ermöglichen auch unsere kinder
und legen auch monatlich
dazu sagte kuhl das war es mit 13 fragen
vielen vielen dank euch warum ist es
eigentlich für alle gut wenn es mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit gibt finde das hat
die debatte heute voll gezeigt und das
nehme ich auf jeden fall auf nämlich mit
ich wünsche mir nach dieser
diskussionsrunde dass wir eine
chancengleichheit in deutschland haben
unabhängig vom sozialen herkunft von der
hautfarbe von der religion und auch vom
geschlecht
das wäre mein wunsch also mein traum ist
dass wir ihr talent schulen in
deutschland haben die dahin gesetzt
werden wo es viertel gibt die besonders
schwierig sind wo besonders viele
menschen vielleicht in hartz 4 leben
oder kein deutsch zu hause gesprochen
wird und wo leute vielleicht noch mehr
unterstützung brauchen in der diskussion
haben die auch
angesprochen dass leute nicht nur geld
brauchen zur unterstützung sondern auch
wirklich emotionale komponenten und das
war für mich etwas wo ich mich absolut
sehen konnte auch in anderen seite als
sie das mal geschlagen haben das ist
immer okay nach hilfe zu fragen weil
damit kann erst wirklich was beginnen
also trau dich nach hilfe zu fragen
du lebst das richtig hier könnt ihr sehr
gerne unseren kanal abonnieren und hier
oben findet er ein weiteres video von 13
fragen zum thema gender gerechte sprache
zum thema der heutigen folge findet sich
hier ein weiteres video